hey crazies we're going to cover some
big questions today is the universe
really incident doesn't have an edge
how can it be flat so what compasses mul
online okay maybe not that last one
before we even try to answer these we're
going to need to clarify something first
the word universe can mean a bunch of
different things merriam-webster says
the scientific definition is all of
space and everything in it including
stars planets galaxies etc but when most
people refer to the universe they're
only talking about the stuff that we can
see that's what astronomers call the
observable universe and it's definitely
not infinite in every direction we see a
blotchy shell of hydrogen atoms
completely enclosing us the light from
those atoms is called the Cosmic
Microwave Background or CMB and it's
coming from a distance of about 13.8
billion light years away so you might be
inclined to say the observable universe
is twenty seven point six billion
light-years across but the speed of
light is finite so the farther out we
look the further back in time we look if
this was emitted from 13.8 billion
light-years away then it was emitted
from there 13.8 billion years ago so it
gives us a decent estimate of the age of
the observable universe but not its size
just just stop and think about this for
a minute what you're looking at is the
formation of the first ever hydrogen
atom this is what the whole observable
universe looked like 13.8 billion years
ago
[Music]
yeah okay so to get the current size we
need to adjust for the time difference
space has expanded since that light was
emitted so the edge is now forty six
point five billion light years away
meaning the observable universe is 93
billion light years across very big but
still finite
however the observable universe is
probably not the entire universe
everything we're capable of observing
must be within our past light cone the
rest is behind a cloak of invisibility
known as the cosmic horizon since that
horizon grows over time you'd expect it
to reveal more things to us
unfortunately the universe seems to be
accelerating in its expansion so the
galaxies are moving farther apart faster
than the cosmic horizon growth the
observable universe is getting lonelier
as time goes on but what about the
entire universe is that infinite well
that depends on a few things we're going
deep since we can't measure anything
beyond the cosmic horizon we're going to
have to be a little more creative with
the stuff inside it two things will help
with this curvature and topology
basically we need to know both local and
global properties and since local stuff
is easier to understand
we'll start with curvature how locals
infinitesimally local considering the
scale of the observable universe you
might think this box is pretty local but
that's far too big for fundamental
physics so then you might make the box
smaller like this not small enough if
there's any kind of real size for that
box all you'll ever see is an average
curvature and you all know how I feel
about averages it's the number that only
exists on paper it has no physical
meaning what we need is an infinitesimal
box a size that's infinitely small yet
still not zero when it comes to
representing curvature those
infinitesimal come packaged in something
we call a metric and each metric can be
written in a wide variety of coordinates
and let me just show you if you want to
take space-time and divide it into
infinitesimally pieces those pieces will
have four dimensions three for space and
one for time a different choice of
coordinates can change the shape of
those pieces but curvature can change
their shape and size a metric puts all
of that information in one place and it
gives us everything we need to develop
concepts about length
since volume or even the passage of time
this is what we need to understand what
the universe looks like just keep in
mind these pieces aren't necessarily
real physical pieces they're just
imaginary pieces that help us write
equations
speaking of which behold the three
millimeter robertson-walker metric or FL
RW metric for short yes there's a lot
going on here so let's try to make
better sense of it we could actually
write it as simple as this where this a
is called the scale factor representing
the universe's expansion so basically
this tells us that space expands but
time does it if we wanted to get a
little more information out of it we
could write it like this which tells us
the overall curvature of space-time is
inward and outward that means the
universe is spherically symmetric or
isotropic but a better way to put that
is that it looks the same in all
direction so what does this mean for the
size of the universe I'm getting there
okay the size of the universe hinges on
wherever this case falls on the number
line if it's exactly zero the universe
is called
flat side note flat doesn't mean flat
like a piece of paper it just means that
any shape in any slice of space-time has
the same properties as that shape in a
flat piece of paper the universe is most
definitely not a piece of paper and
inside note the easiest shape to
consider is a triangle angles in a flat
triangle add to be exactly 180 degrees
so that's what they'll do in its last
space-time if the K is positive though
angles in a triangle will add to be more
than 180 degrees the universe could have
fear ellipsoid or even doughnut shaped
slices if the K is negative angles in a
triangle will add to be less than 180
degrees slices could be shaped like a
hyperboloid so what does this mean for
the size of the universe a right or
right if the universe has positive
curvature it cannot be infinite
it must curve back on itself and be
fully night with no edges if the
universe is flat or has negative
curvature it could be finite or infinite
it depends on topology we mentioned
earlier that a sphere and a doughnut
have the same type of curvature positive
curvature but they don't have the same
topology because of this giant gaping
hole to know the shape of the universe
completely
we need to know what topology this is
where things get super tricky we can
only take measurements in our observable
part of the universe so it might be
impossible to measure topology but we
can definitely measure curvature and if
the universe has positive curvature we
know that it's finite regardless of its
topology we can draw a triangle measure
the angles add them up and we get
exactly 180 degrees or I refuse to
accept the universe is flat we're going
to need a bigger triangle let's use the
CMB from earlier the earth can be one
corner then we'll pick the other two
corners to be in the hydrogen emitting
the CMB
we know the lengths of all the sides so
we can get the angle to yes
adding up the angles we get exactly 180
degrees well ok using an unimaginable
amount of data collected from the swamp
Space Telescope we see that the universe
is pretty flat that doesn't necessarily
mean the universe is infinite though
this is an example of a flat finite
universe it's kind of like a soccer ball
with flat faces but most cosmologists
don't get behind topologies like that
this is one of those places where
Occam's razor becomes important which
says when presented with two competing
hypotheses explaining and observation
you should err on the side of caution
and start with the one with the fewest
assumption in other words start with the
simplest one so while the soccer ball
shape might be possible it is most
definitely not simple cosmologists stick
to what they call trivial solution which
means simple shapes with no edge in
which case a flat universe must be
infinite the plug Space Telescope isn't
perfect though there's still 8.4 percent
margin of error there still could be
some curvature to the overall universe
as long as it's unimaginably larger than
the observable heart I'm still holding
out for that finite universe with
positive curvature but just because your
universe is finite in size doesn't mean
that it's totally finite physics still
needs a lot of infinity to support it
I'll explain why getting akiles from A
to B requires you to assume that there
are way more numbers in this distance
than you might have imagined hmm that
sounds interesting you should check that
out all right
raises that's it for today thanks for
liking and sharing this video don't
forget to subscribe if you'd like to
keep up with us and until next time
remember it's okay to be a little crazy
in the last video we learned about how
far apart things are in space come our
response time and Harry's was impressed
that the moon is so far away but could
still affect the time yeah I know right
how crazy is that in all fairness though
it's not the only reason the tide passed
the oceans also need a lot of fluid
pressure so what helps that they're all
connected to each other while the moon
is the primary cause of the tide
it is not the only reason they happen
200 guess that if we wanted to place the
next closest star in our scale model it
would probably have to be in space and
indeed it would a little over 4 light
years away there's this star system with
free sergeant the closest of the 3 is a
little red dwarf known as Proxima
Centauri and on our scale it would be
the size of a small car but located
twice as far as the real actual moon
that mr. TC was faster than light travel
but says that Einstein is standing in
the way with a barbed wire baseball bat
a barbed wire baseball bat really I'm
fine is German and he's smart so
obviously he would be using a two-handed
longsword notices Vai Honda also the
Alcubierre drive might be a way to
outmaneuver an Alexandra Ochoa wants the
moon to be closer I don't think that's
such a good idea if the moon were
explosives most people think it would
orbit the Earth every 8.3 hours and as
Thomas Jackson said we have a hard time
keeping satellites in orbit also I'm not
sure how that would affect the tide
Elliot gray brought up the game majora's
mask and honestly it kept popping into
my head the whole time I was editing he
wondered what would happen if the moon
crashed into the earth it became in fast
enough we could stay in one team but the
moon in Majora's Mask took days to come
down that's plenty of time for
gravitational tidal forces to break up
the moon probably turning it into a big
ring around the earth well until the
pieces finally came
down you can science it pointed out as
the moon reflector isn't just for NASA
if you have a throwing in a signal you
can use it too
it's a retroreflector so what returns
the light back to exactly where it came
from no matter what angle you're at
anyway crazies thanks for watching and
don't forget to check out looking-glass
universe see you next time
[Music]